This hell has taken too much from me. I can
finally get out of this hell.
[Music] What
is this? Welcome to the
new world, to all the new students. I've been
looking around for a while now. What's going on? I
'm Plum Schneizer from Beta class.
I can use a big weapon, so I
wanted to know who my father was.I'm going to take an exam, and
only the top 600 students will be able to enroll.I don't know why this happened,
but I won't let that tragedy happen again.The
content of the exam is a shadow.
Clear the world of
Désir Armand Don't
mess with him. I'm the one who will
defeat him. I'll show you my ability to rebuild this world. You're
strong, but you're still not good enough. At
this
level, the same future will repeat itself.  What you should
have is a lighter rapier. I won't
give you time to count backwards. I'll use
all my strength to defeat you. We'll become even stronger
in order to overcome that tragedy.
[Music]